ELLIE POWERS: So I'm
going to talk today
about getting the
most from Google Play.
My name is Ellie Powers.
I'm a product manager
on the Google Play team.
And I work on apps.
Many of you are here
building apps, but why?
Right?
Why are we doing this?
Well, for some of
us, it's because we
have a particular idea that
we're really passionate about,
and we want to get
out into the world.
For some of us,
it's because we have
an idea for an exciting
new business that
doesn't exist yet.
And the sort of world
that we're talking about
is this multi-device,
multi-billion person world
that's grown over the
past decade or so.
And we're also going to talk
about how Google, specifically
Google Play, is
uniquely positioned
to help you get your idea
and your business out
into the world and as
successful as possible.
So first a little bit about me.
I love to travel.
I've been to countries
all over the world.
And my favorite
thing when I travel
is to go to a place
that's going to make
me feel a little bit
out of my element.
The other reason
I love to travel
is they tell me
that it's supposed
to be a really good idea to get
away from your work from time
to time.
But unfortunately, when
you work on mobile apps,
this is getting really
hard to do actually.
So about a year ago, I went on
a trip to Thailand and Cambodia.
And when I was on the subways
in Thailand thinking-- yeah,
I'll get away from my work-- I'm
seeing ads for Android games.
And then I go to the
markets in Cambodia
and I see Android
devices for sale.
And it's really a nice reminder
that the work that we're
doing here, to build this
mobile ecosystem together,
is really reaching people
all over the world.
And today here we are
in Moscone Center,
and we're seeing that
the wave of Android
is now going in both directions.
Not only are our
users everywhere,
but there are developers
all over the globe.
Just actually across
here on the floor here,
we have a developer
called Rayark, also
from Southeast Asia.
And they've made a beautiful,
immersive game experience.
And if you haven't seen
it yet, I definitely
recommend that you go and
check it out afterwards.
So these are the sorts of
strong mobile ecosystems
that we're building
all around the world
and they're tied together
through Google Play.
So how did Google get involved
in this whole mobile apps
thing?
Let's go a little bit further
back into Google's history.
So my first experience
with Google was this box.
And you could just
type stuff into the box
and it would just
find things for you.
It was magic.
And this was the first
opportunity that a lot of us
had to see just how
big the world was,
and that seemingly far
away ideas and places
were now becoming within reach.
And so this was what
Google started out with,
connecting people with the
information and the products
that they were interested in.
So what happened next?
Well, on April 1,
2004, Gmail launched.
In 2005, YouTube joined Google.
And then with maps and
other key launches,
Google became known for
customer-centric internet
experiences and really,
really enormous scale.
I mean, you may
have remembered what
a big deal it was
over 10 years ago
when you finally got a whole
gigabyte for your online email
where people were offering
just a fraction of that.
And this meant that
your information
could be truly
accessible from anywhere.
And this was
happening on the web.
It was happening on
desktop computers.
Maybe you remember
having a dial-up modem
and that big upgrade
moment to DSL.
And this was cool and exciting.
And let's fast forward to today.
Well, Android had
joined back in 2005.
What's happened in
those almost 10 years
is that we've now moved
on to the next chapter
of the internet.
We have billions of
people connecting.
Many of them are using
Android as their first device.
And what happens?
What is the difference
between your desktop computer
and a website with your
mobile device today?
You're now in this kind of
loop of constant interaction.
You've replaced
clicking and typing
with touch screens, voice
controls, and sensors.
And Google's still doing
what Google has always
done best which is
connecting people
with the information
and products
that they find most interesting.
What this means here is now
connecting people with the apps
that they love on
a range of devices.
So what we're going
to do today is
talk about what this means
to developers like all of us.
So again, why do we develop?
Why do we build apps?
It's to get our ideas and
businesses out into the world.
And an app is
definitely the best way
to do that in this day and age.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is how your app can reach the
right users at the right time,
and the approach
that you'll take
is going to depend on
what stage your app is in.
So first, I want
to talk to those
of you who are just
getting started.
Maybe you've just built an app
or you have an idea for one.
You don't have any
users yet, so that'll
be your first challenge.
So before you publish
your app, you probably
want to understand this
ecosystem that you're joining,
and that's Google Play.
So what is Play?
Play is an ecosystem of apps,
developers, and the store.
We have the one billion devices
that were discussed before
and the people who use them.
Well over a million
apps are in the store.
And behind the scenes,
we have massively
scaled cloud computing
services that
can help to do everything that
we're going to talk about next.
What I think about what Google
Play really is at its core
is a matchmaker.
If I'm a user, it's going to try
to match me with a sort of app
that I'm going to want.
Maybe I'm looking for that
app, or maybe I don't even
know I'm looking and it's just
helping me discover something
new about what my device can do.
And then on the other
side, if I have an app,
it's going to match me
with the sort of users
who are going to be
interested in my app.
So let's start out
with something new,
something that's
coming soon, something
that we're incredibly
excited about.
So earlier in the keynote,
you heard the discussion
about material design.
And on Play we're
really trying to take
this beautiful, interactive
layout to heart.
Now, when you launch a
new app and you put it up
on the Play store,
you really want
to make a great
first impression.
So we've decided to
make the store listing
on Google Play even
more appealing.
And by the way, this is
just a general concept.
It's not totally
done, but we wanted
to share with you early
so that you can understand
the context in which your
app will be available.
So at the top you can see this
beautiful feature graphic.
And at the bottom you can
see a quick text summary
where you can explain to users
exactly what your app will
for them.
So you might want to go
into the Developer Console
and make sure that you
actually have this graphic
and text available so that
when we roll this out,
your app will be ready.
And in the middle
here, you're going
to see the reasons why the user
may want to install the app.
So for example, a great
reason to install the app
is it's got a high star rating.
So we call that
out really clearly.
Or maybe it's got
a lot of downloads.
Or maybe, it's
because your friend
has installed it and
given it a high rating.
So this is going to
be rolling out soon,
and we hope that it'll help you
make your apps give a better
first impression.
OK.
When I go out in the world and
actually talk to Android users,
I like to ask them how they
find about their favorite apps.
The number one reason I hear
again and again is-- well,
I found this app because
my friend told me about it.
Perfectly natural.
And that's why on
Google Play we're
trying to reflect
the same behavior.
Whenever we see that your friend
has rated or plus-oned an app,
we tell you about it.
And we also show you why we
make each [? introduction. ?]
We don't just say
install the app.
We say you should
install this app because.
So what this does is it
creates a ripple effect.
If you find one user
who installs your app
and gives you a
rating of plus 1,
it'll ripple out to effect
all of their friends
and build more momentum
behind your app.
You can also now
follow top brands
like Wired or the New
Yorker, or even celebrities.
So we talked about Play
being a matchmaker.
How do we do this?
We're using the
full power of Google
and the user's
full profile to be
able to target the right
app to the right user
at the right time.
We've also created
these targeted groups
of apps based on user interests.
So here, you can
see racing games
and you can also see
food and drink apps.
And we don't necessarily show
these groups to everybody, only
to the people who we know
have these interests.
We also show personalized
recommendations
that are based on a
whole variety of things
we know about the
user, including
what their friends
have recommended.
And Play Games is
something that's
really helpful for those of
you who are making game apps.
Play Game Services
are a great way
to enhance your app, to make
it more social and more fun.
We launched it last
year at I/O, and we've
heard that it's a great
way to discover more games
and also to engage
with the games
that you're already playing.
So today at I/O we announced
some really exciting features,
including the new user profile,
which you can see here.
It's showing which games you
play in the achievements.
For example, on the
screenshot behind me
you can see how many
experience points
that this particular
user has accumulated
in different types of games.
And then you can
also create what
are called quests
inside your app.
You can say-- hey, user, why
don't you go and accomplish
this particular objective
in a limited time.
And then we'll also go and show
those quests in the Play Games
app to help recruit new users.
So if a user is looking for
your app, if you're a developer,
you want to be absolutely
sure that that user will
find that app no matter
where they're looking.
And so that's why it's
integrated with Google Search.
So if someone is on an
Android device and searches
for your app in
Google Search that
could be in Chrome or maybe
in the Google search app,
will actually show your
apps in the search results
in a nice way with an
easy install button
so they can install the
app directly from there.
And then a new feature that
we're rolling out this year,
and we're very
happy to say is now
available to all
developers, is app indexing.
So you're probably familiar
with the idea of Google indexing
websites, but actually, Google
can do basically the same thing
with apps too.
So what does this
allow us to do?
It can allow us to link a
search with a particular page
inside an app that a user
already has in your device.
So let's give an example.
So here, the user
is saying-- I want
to search for a Chromecast,
where can I buy it?
And it turns out
this user already
had the Walmart app installed.
So when they click
on the link, it'll
actually launch the
Chromecast app-- sorry,
launch the Walmart
app-- directly
to the Chromecast page.
And so this means that
we're giving the user
the best possible
experience on their device.
So if you're interested
in trying this out now,
this will be available
in the developer console
through a special
link where you can
link your app to your website.
OK.
So that's how Play can
act as a matchmaker.
And you publish your app,
and a lot of this goodness
just happens for
you automatically.
We help you get a lot of
your reach for your app
without a lot of effort.
So now, I want to talk to
those of you who already have
an app that's good, and you
already have some users,
but you want to go
to the next level.
You want to make your app great.
So your next step
is to find a way
to make your app one that
everyone wants to come back to.
And you want to
use Play to focus
on finding the exact right
audience for your app too.
So here's the whole
life cycle of an app.
Right?
Design, develop, distribute.
And this week,
you're going to be
going to tons of
different sessions.
So we're just going to
focus on a few things here.
Let's take a look at how
we can combine the best
that the Google has to offer
for Google Play developers.
So from building to promoting
and monetizing your app,
we have a lot of really
interesting solutions
available.
So let's say we're
launching a new app.
[? Urs ?] showed us
some amazing stuff
in the new Cloud Platform.
And the classic problem
we hear from developers
is-- I want to build something
that's ready for massive scale,
but I don't have a huge budget
on day one, so what do I do?
So we've actually created the
Cloud Platform mobile starter
kit.
And what this can do
for you is allow you
with very little programming
to be able to set up
your back-end infrastructure,
and then if you need to scale
you can just do it like that.
And this allows you to
scale to huge applications
and get that super
fast performance
that you expect from Google.
Now, if you're
thinking about making
your application richer--
maybe through, let's say,
the maps API or
the in-app billing
API-- the best way to
do that integration
is through the
Google Play Services.
Now, this is something
that we automatically
install in the user's devices.
And most importantly,
it's kept up to date.
So what does this mean for you?
You can just make calls directly
to Google Play Services.
There's no SDK to maintain.
You don't have to wait
for any sort of roll-out.
So you can access these
new features immediately.
So at I/O today, we announced
new activity recognition
services, including
walking and running.
So you can make a really
interactive application
that knows what the
user's doing physically.
And we also
announced Cloud Save.
The Cloud Save API allows you
to synchronize data easily
with your mobile applications
without any sort of background
programming.
And what this gives
you, for the user,
is the ability to sync
data quickly and easily
when the user goes
offline and online
and works across
multiple devices.
OK.
So you have a good
app and you're
ready to get it into the world.
Well, we've heard from
a bunch of developers
that as they scale and go beyond
just one application and one
language to dozens
of applications
and dozens of
languages, it can get
to be a little bit
difficult to manage.
You want to produce a
store listing that's
going to give a great
tailored experience.
If you're in a certain
language, so that
would mean localized text
and localized graphics.
Or, if you're on,
let's say, a tablet,
you want to provide
tablet screenshots too.
And this ends up meaning that
you have to copy and paste
a ton of times or manage
hundreds of assets.
So we have a solution that we're
very happy to announce today.
With the new Developer
Publishing API,
you'll be able to
integrate the publishing
process with your
existing build system.
So you'll be able to manage your
beta testing, stage roll-outs,
production releases,
and all of the assets
and images and graphics that
you're looking to roll out.
You can even manage your
in-app product catalog as well.
So this is currently
in a closed beta,
and we're looking to
roll it out more soon.
OK.
So last year when we
talked about beta testing,
we were really excited to
tell all of our developers
that this feature was coming.
But I've got to say, I
was pretty overwhelmed
by the reaction.
Developers have
really taken this on
and made some amazing things
happen for these features.
And I wanted to talk with
you about one developer who's
actually here in the
audience today, ZenStudios.
So they had a new game that
they were going to launch,
CastleStorm-Free to Siege.
And if you're a
game developer, you
know that with every new title
you put so much work into it,
and you want it to be
perfect when you launch it.
So how do you do this?
Well, ZenStudios decided to
use the beta testing feature.
They decided to make
it a public beta,
although they could
have kept it private.
And they said-- maybe, we
can get about 1,000 users.
So they posted it
on their website.
They posted it on social media.
Three days later,
they had 3,000 users
and it soon expanded
to about 6,000 users.
So they had a huge amount of
interest in this beta test.
And because they care so much
about the user experience
and making their
game great, they
said give us your
honest feedback.
And users, absolutely,
they came back
with all sorts of great stuff.
They said that the controls in a
couple places were hard to use.
They mentioned exactly
where they were frustrated,
and this allowed
ZenStudios to be
able to improve user retention
at some tricky points.
The other feedback
they got was-- well,
different sorts of users
and different countries
than they had expected actually
wanted to play their game.
So they actually ended
up modifying their launch
countries.
And they were able to give
a bit of sense of how much
marketing budget that they
should invest for this game
because they were able to see
what some of the early metrics
might look like.
So this early data
and analytics meant
that they had a much
more successful launch.
Usually, what game
developers end up doing is
they do a small launch in
maybe a certain smaller
country like, let's say, Canada.
Or, they might spend a
bunch of money up-front
on trying to do some
paid user acquisition.
But in this case,
ZenStudios didn't
need to do either
of these things.
So the result was they had
a really successful launch.
They got a star
rating of 4.5 stars.
And they now have
hundreds of thousands
of happy users
playing their game.
Wrong slide.
OK.
So next, we're going to
talk about staged rollouts.
This feature is all about
keeping the momentum
going when you push out
new versions of your app.
When we talked with Jack
Threads, they said-- hey,
we want to redo our
Android app and make it
the best mobile experience ever.
But if you're going to
take on a project this big,
you're going to
be really worried.
If you have an
eCommerce app, you'd
be afraid to touch
the checkout flow
because you might
break everything.
Can you imagine having an
eCommerce app and no one
could buy anything
for a few days?
That would be a huge problem.
So what they said was
with staged rollouts,
they were willing to touch
these trickier bits of code
and make such a fundamental
change without all
this worry about breaking stuff.
And they said that they
can now move much more
quickly with their small team.
During the rollouts,
what they do is they
check the desired metrics,
the stats, the ratings,
the installs, and the
crashes, and make sure
that this new version is
performing at least as
well as the previous one.
So as a result, they
now use staged rollouts
with every single
launch they do.
And most importantly,
because Google Play
is such a great platform
for trying new stuff,
they actually try out their
new features on Android first.
OK.
So you can see why we
launched beta testing
and staged rollouts, to help
developers make great apps.
So I wanted to
share a few numbers
about how much of a
response that we've gotten.
We've had over 80,000 apps
use beta testing so far.
And if you look at all the apps
that have tried this feature,
they have an average rating of
over 4.2 stars, which is great.
This is clear evidence
that people are really
using this to improve the
quality of their apps.
And over a third
of the apps that we
see coming from our top
charts are using beta testing.
And many of them are
using staged rollouts too.
It's become a best
practice at Google as well.
OK.
So another thing I
hear from developers
is-- I have limited resources, a
small team, and a lot of ideas,
so how do I know what
to focus on first?
So optimization
tips is something
we rolled out last year to
help you localize your apps.
So for example, if
we notice that you've
gotten a lot of users
in a certain country,
but your app isn't available
in their native language,
we let you know.
Or for example, other
types of opportunities.
Like, if we notice that
you haven't upgraded yet
to the new in-app
billing V3 API and that
might be hurting your sales,
we let you know about that too.
So these are all opportunities
to improve your app
and get more out of Google Play.
And you said in response
to that-- I also
want to know when
something's gone wrong.
And so in response to
that, we announced alerts.
So we'll let you
know if you launch
a new version of your app
and your ratings go down.
Developers like
this too, and what
we heard from you was-- well,
I want to find out even sooner.
So we're also releasing a way
that you can now go and sign up
to receive email
alerts every time you
get a new alert in the Google
Play Developer Console.
OK.
So once you have your app
and it's doing pretty well,
you probably want to
take a closer look
at what users are
doing inside your app.
And so that's where Google
Analytics can come in.
It's the easiest way to
get this deep insight
into in-app behavior.
And it also can
allow you to see how
users behave as they move
from your mobile apps
across different
platforms to the web.
So one of the best things
about Google Analytics,
why it's so easy
to integrate, is
it uses the Google
Play Services which
is already on the user's device.
This just means that you need
only a couple of lines of code
added to your application with--
and you don't blow your APK
size by adding
another Analytics SDK.
And once you get a sense of what
people are doing in your app,
then the next thing you
want to do is experiment.
So what you can do here
is set up a few goals.
Maybe your goal is to have
your users watch more videos,
or make more purchases,
or things like that.
You set the goal.
Then you can set up a
couple of different options,
and over time it'll
switch automatically
to whatever the best option is.
So last year, we
announced that we
were helping you identify which
of your marketing campaigns
was the most successful at
recruiting new valuable users.
So what you can do here
is for each campaign,
you can see how many users view,
install, and launch your app.
And that means you'll
end up focusing on
the most effective user
acquisition channels
and fine-tuning your campaigns.
And usually we find
with developers
as they get more
sophisticated, they'll
define some sort
of group of users
that they think is
the most valuable.
So for example, in
this game, we might
say that we want
to track users who
came in through a
certain campaign.
They've reached at
least level seven,
and let's say that
they've spent $5.
And you can track how that group
of users is doing over time.
So we've seen freemium apps
become the most popular way
to monetize on Google Play.
And so AdMob recently
launched a new product
to help make these freemium
apps more relevant and more
successful.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
So when you're
having an app that's
monetized through
in-app purchases,
it's really important
to reach the right user
at the right time with the right
in-app product that constitutes
a meaningful interaction
for the user,
and some time when they're
willing to make a purchase,
basically.
So these ads can
really help improve
the relevance of
the in-app products
that you're showing to users.
And if you've already set
up that segment of people
who came in through Campaign
X and are on level seven
and have spent at least
$5 in Google Analytics,
you can use these user
segments here in AdMob
to be able to show those
right ads at the right time.
We talk to our best
developers and we
try to understand how
they got so successful
from a financial perspective.
And then we want to make
that information available
and that top expertise part
of the regular experience
in the developer console.
So some of the top metrics
we find our best developers
tracking are the average
revenue per paying
user and the number of buyers
that they have in their app.
So we've added these
now, and we're also
going to offer breakdowns
by country so that you
can see how are these important
metrics tracking as you expand
your business into new markets.
OK.
Another trend that we've
seen is subscriptions.
We're seeing more and more
apps moving to this model
and it's become the
fastest growing way
to make money in apps.
And this can be really
helpful for your app,
especially if it
has fresh content
or is frequently updated.
And if you can manage to
find the right product,
it can make a great,
steady recurring revenue
stream for your users--
for your business, too.
So this year at I/O, we're
very happy to announce
that we're going to be rolling
out weekly and seasonal
subscriptions pretty soon.
So if you're making a
World Cup app, for example,
this can be the right way
to structure that offering
to users.
OK.
So earlier today, we
announced that we're
going to be offering direct
carrier billing on tablets.
All the user has to do is
set it up on their smartphone
and it'll keep working
on their tablets.
And direct carrier
billing is super popular,
and it's available on about
50 percent of all play users.
We've also seen with the launch
of PayPal and gift cards,
there's just more and more
ways for users around the globe
to pay.
So what this means is
as our business expands
and more people in all
over the world buy devices,
they're able to make
purchases as well.
OK.
So let's say that you're a
developer who has a great app.
You're already measuring
your business carefully,
and your next step is to be
part of the next big thing.
So here's a couple of
advanced strategies
if this is the place
that your app is in.
So previously, we were
talking about reaching
users one by one, but we
have some new exciting ways
to reach users in groups
through the organizations
that they're a part of.
So if you have an
app that's targeted
towards educational purposes,
particularly classroom
education, you can submit
your app for inclusion
in Play for education.
What this does is it
puts your educational app
in front of school
administrators and teachers,
and this opens up a
new opportunity for you
through bulk purchasing.
So if you haven't signed
up for this program
yet but you think your
app should be part of it,
you can sign up in
the developer console.
And then announced
earlier today, we've
talked about how
we're making Android
much much better
for enterprises.
So this is another way to
reach users and groups.
If you have an app that's
great for people in a business
context, this can be a fantastic
way to expand your reach.
We're going to be making
a bunch of changes
across the Android platform
and across Play when
system administrators
will be able to say-- hey,
I want to take this
app and make it
available to my whole company.
So stay tuned.
This is a very new
program and we're
excited to tell you more soon.
So Android Wear is
something you've
seen a lot of people
talking about today,
and it's something that we're
incredibly excited about.
This is an
opportunity for a user
to have a device with
them all the time
and not just in their pocket or
in their bag, but on their arm.
And there's a lot of new
interaction opportunities
that come up there.
So when we told the
Huffington Post about this--
they were one of
our early partners--
and they said-- yeah, this would
be a really cool opportunity.
There app already worked
great on phones and tablets,
and they were looking to keep
being part of that leading
device availability.
So they decided to extend
their app onto the watch.
One of the cool
features they added
was the ability to get headline
alerts 24/7 for their biggest
news aficionados.
And you can also share
stories really easily
without even taking your
phone out of your pocket.
So how Google Play is helping
expand onto these new devices
is by knowing which
devices a user has.
And then we can
surface the groups
of the best apps
for those devices
to those specific
users who have them.
And this helps you
reach the right users
in the ecosystem for
these specialized devices
that you build apps for.
OK.
So now we're going to
talk about the thing
that I am the most
excited about,
compared to everything else.
We all talked about the
promise of the internet,
connecting the whole
world, and we finally
have the ability to
realize that promise
in the very near future.
So in the mid-1990s,
it took about ten years
to connect the first billion
people to the internet.
Then it took about five
years for the second billion.
And the third billion should
be connected just about any day
now.
We're almost there.
And for many of
these people, Android
is really their first computer.
It's their first experience
at being connected and seeing
how the internet can
enhance their lives.
And the way that
this has turned out
is that all these three billion
people are on mobile devices
and they want apps.
So if you want to reach
every person in the world,
you need to understand
what countries they're in.
And we can see what top
countries are available.
Sure, the US is on
there, but it's only
a teeny, teeny part
of that big doughnut.
So when you're thinking
about how to reach the world
and how to grow
your business, it's
great to think about
other countries, and all
the opportunities
there for users
who want a lot of
the same things,
or sometimes different
things for mobile apps.
And an app should also
speak the user's language.
Yes, English is
popular, but also
Chinese, Spanish, Japanese,
Portuguese, et cetera.
And that's what Samuel Braff
from textPlus told us about.
His challenge was he wanted
to make this great messaging
app that would help
users exchange messages
or make calls for free
or for a small fee.
And he realized that in order
to get people fully engaged
with this application,
they needed
to really understand
what the app did.
And that meant explaining
the features clearly
in the user's native language.
So he looked at which countries
outside the US and Canada,
where he had initially
launched, had some usage,
and he decided to localize.
He saw four times the growth
in the non-English speaking
markets since then.
When we launched the app
translation service last year,
the company was pretty
quick to get involved.
And here are the
reasons why they told us
that they've stuck with our
app translation service.
First of all, it's an XML file.
With previous
services, they'd have
to copy and paste
all their strings.
The turnaround time
was also very quick,
so there were no more delayed
releases due to translation.
And it was affordable,
so that meant
that they could localize
into more markets.
So this strategy has helped them
reach over 100 million people
globally, and Android is a
key part of that strategy.
So this is what the app
translation service looks like.
First, we show you
some optimization tips
recommending where
you might want
to consider
translating your app.
Then you can request
the languages
that you want to translate
into and pay easily.
You get back a professional
translation pretty quickly.
OK.
So what have we
talked about today?
The world's population is
about 7 billion people.
About 3 billion of them are
connected to the internet.
And there's a billion or so
Android devices actively being
used.
And this is really exciting.
Play is available on more
devices than any other app
store in the world.
And so it's the
best way to reach
the right user at
the right time.
So in this new mobile
world, connecting everybody
is really exciting.
And this is, for me, why
I got into technology,
and I think for
many of you as well.
So we know that
people really want
to find great apps to
connect with each other
and to really make the
most of their lives
and enhance what they're
doing on a daily basis.
And so with Google, we're
really happy to be helping
users find these
great experiences.
Connecting people with the
apps and the information
that they're looking
for so that they
can make the most of their
devices and their lives.
So thank you to everyone
here for helping
us build these experiences and
being part of this new world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
We'll take questions.
It would be great if you have
a question if you could come up
to this microphone here
or that microphone there.
No question.
Great.
Oh, wait.
One question.
We have one-- wait, maybe.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
interested in what
the future is for subscription
billing in the Play store.
One thing we've noticed, and
we had a big rollout of it
this year, is the lack
of testing tools involved
in a namely sandbox testing.
It's actually really
hard to test expiration
of subscriptions
and also get data
on how many people are
renewing and basically
what your turnover rate
is, what your churn rate
is on subscriptions.
So I just wanted
to see if you have
any plans on enhancing
that [? future step. ?]
ELLIE POWERS: So it's really
about trusting subscriptions?
Or were there some
other figures there too
that you're wondering about.
AUDIENCE: Really
just subscriptions.
I mean, right now you guys
have really good tools
for just one-off consumable
purchases in the in-app store.
But more, the
subscriptions are lacking.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah.
That's a great point.
I think it's a new product.
It's one that we've been
really excited to see so much
take up of over the
past year or so.
I think we've definitely
heard the issues that you're
bringing up, especially
around testing.
And we don't have anything
to announce right now,
but we're definitely
looking into it.
So thanks for raising that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks for your talk.
You mentioned Google Play
for Education and the ability
to do bulk purchasing.
What about apps that are
freemium with in-app purchases?
Do you have a timeline for
being able to do bulk purchasing
on in-app purchases, either
in Google Play for Education
or in general for businesses?
ELLIE POWERS: That's
a great question.
I think as we're seeing more and
more organizations being really
keen to adopt Android
and Google Play
to distribute to
their users, it's
becoming something that's
more pertinent to what
these companies and
schools are looking to do.
So we don't have anything
to announce today.
But yes, I think
we're looking into it
and we're aware
that it's becoming
more and more of an
issue, especially as we're
seeing more and more even
educational apps moved
to a freemium model.
So we are definitely
looking into it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
what the state or plans are
for a business-to-business
app store,
such that we can do
business-to-business apps that
are centrally managed,
rather than delivered ad hoc.
ELLIE POWERS: Hmm.
So business-to-business store.
So I guess we're not
announcing everything
yet about the new
improvements that we're
making for Android
on enterprise.
But probably the sorts of
things that we're looking at
are a greater ability
for, let's say,
an IT administrator at a
company to take initiative
to make purchases of
apps, or to decide which
apps can be available on users.
So maybe we can talk
more about it afterwards,
but we're definitely
looking at ways
that a company can say--
this is a software we want
to have available to our
company, make that purchase,
and then distribute it
out to the right people
in the company.
It's definitely something we're
thinking a lot about as part
of these enterprise
projects that we're doing.
AUDIENCE: OK, but
specifically as far as custom
made applications,
specifically for a client.
ELLIE POWERS: Oh, I see.
So something that's just a
bespoke application for-- yeah,
we should probably talk
offline about that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Yes?
[? AUDIENCE: Exclusive ?] of
all the countries which have
different RPU.
Like, in India, the
ad pool is very low
as comparatively people
do less in-app purchases.
So the only way to get
the [? downwards ?]
is only the organic traffic.
And when we see the
offering sections
and we see the radio
sections of the store,
we see very different type of
apps that should not be there.
You know that there
is some problem there.
So is Google working
out how to fix
the problem of getting
more organic traffic
for the [? represent? ?]
If the developers can hold
the logic behind this
reason, you can get a better
organic traffic, or if you do
this, then this would happen.
Because this is a very important
question for the countries
where the RPU is very low.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah.
So just to make sure I
understand your question,
I think you're asking
about what are we
doing to help getting
organic traffic,
especially in markets where
the RPU doesn't facilitate
spending a lot of money
on paid user acquisition?
Yeah.
I think it's something where
we're looking carefully
at how we can tune
our algorithms best.
I think one of the trends that
we've seen that's definitely
difficult is Google Play
has become very popular.
There's many apps in
store, and everyone
wants to make sure
that they're getting
their share of that traffic.
So we've definitely been looking
at ways to tune the store.
And I think when we
talk about things
like doing user targeting,
what we're hoping to do
is if I have a mobile device and
my mother has a mobile device,
Google Play should offer
us different things.
And so the great news
there can mean that
rather than offering the
same application to me
and my mother, if you offer us
each a different application,
it's not a loss to any
developer because an app
that I might want, she might
not want, and vice versa.
So I hope through
better personalization,
that's where we're
going to be able to make
the most of the
store real estate
so that we're surfacing
only apps that the user is
likely to be interested
in and not other apps.
But it is a big challenge.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the optimization
depreciation that
Google Play dashboard.
So right now, it's only
focused on the localization,
localizing this language
and that language.
One thing in my
experience I've seen
is that oftentimes the
certain devices which
are popular in the geography.
So for example,
in India, Micromax
is among the top 10 devices.
But in my list of
devices, they feature
on the fifth or sixth number.
You know?
So can you share if my app
is popular in a particular
geography, can the
optimization tip be in a way
that you are populating
[? Russia ?] you might as well.
But this phone, which is
highest download in Russia,
is not in your top ten.
So I might as well optimize
the presence for that.
ELLIE POWERS: Oh, OK.
So just to make sure I
understand your question.
So you're saying if
you're offering your app
in a certain market, you want
to highlight which devices
might be more popular there?
AUDIENCE: I believe my
distribution pattern
across devices should also
shadow the overall distribution
better than the geography.
If I'm not, then I'm leaving
money on the table, right?
ELLIE POWERS: I see.
Yeah, it's a good question.
Yeah, I think we definitely want
to show which devices you have.
But I guess also it gets
a little bit sensitive
because some of our
partners may not necessarily
want to share overall
statistics about that.
But I think it's
a good question.
I think a common question
that we hear from developers
is when they're moving
into a new market,
they definitely want to
be able to understand
which devices they're going
to support, and to make
sure they're not, like you said,
leaving money on the table.
So I think it's an interesting
problem to figure out.
Maybe we could talk
more about it later.
AUDIENCE: Can I have a
follow-up question on the same?
Plus-one seems to be
a big driver for us
for getting the organic traffic.
Intuitively it makes
sense to recommend people
and to plus one the app when
they are in a-- down the
funnel when they're three or
four days into the process.
But some developers
I talk with, they
say it's right at the outset
if you ask them, they do it.
So when is the right time
to push that request.
ELLIE POWERS: That's
a great question.
I actually haven't looked
at the data for that.
I think each
developer will depend.
I've seen, I guess
similar to you,
I've seen a couple developers
and sometimes they say-- hey,
you've used this
app for this long,
it looks like
you're enjoying it,
would you mind
giving us a rating?
So I think it will depend
on your application,
but I haven't actually
looked at the data for that
to see if there was
an optimal time.
But I would guess it probably
varies on the type of app
that you have.
If the user is very
enthusiastic for your app,
then they're probably
more happy to do it.
If they're in the
middle of a task
and doing something that they
consider to be very important,
that may be a distraction
for them at that point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's not a question,
but I'd just
like to hear your
opinion about the gaming
category and the
top-grossing list.
Once you have a strong
title on the top-grossing,
it's very easy for you to
cross-promote and create
other titles that go
up in the same list.
And that makes this
list very static.
So what are the chances
for indie developers,
for new developers,
gaming studios,
to launch games and reach this
top-grossing in the gaming
category?
ELLIE POWERS: You know, I
think if you look at games,
you're right that there are
a lot of very big players
who are very successful.
But I think at the same time,
there's always something new.
Flappy Bird, where
did that come from?
Right?
Somehow that managed
to get to the top.
So I think that's
something that we
look at a lot,
which is how do we
offer this balance between
things that are trending,
things that are really
new, and some people want
those sorts of things, and
other people kind of want
the stuff that's really
well-known big brands.
So I think we offer a
variety of different charts
to be able to do that.
And then we're always
looking at ways
to tweak those
algorithms to make sure
that they're counting
things right.
I think in terms of
indie developers,
we do a lot of different special
featuring programs there.
We put together a lot of
groups of applications
of very high quality games
that we actually call out
is-- these are indie games.
And so certain types of
gamers are really interested
in that type of thing.
And again, I think a
lot of it will come down
to the personalization
whereas if we can find out
what sort of person
likes your application,
then we can show it to that
person, but maybe not to my mom
who might not like
that type of game.
So I think it's definitely
a big challenge.
You have a balance
of big companies
who know what they're doing
and are really, really strong
at being able to do a
great marketing campaign
and building a great app.
And then also
wanting to make sure
that the platform can remain
responsive to new people who
are entering and making really
exciting, different stuff.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about alternative Android app
store markets.
There are a few other ones
besides the Play store.
You had mentioned
with Google Analytics
that it ties in with
the Play Store that's
installed on the device.
There's also other utilities
that are just basic function
utilities of a
person's cellphone.
Like for example, GCM.
So it seems that if I,
as an Android developer,
want to be able to
support a plethora
of different
distribution channels,
I have to bend over
backwards to be
able to support some core
functionality like push
notifications or
Google Analytics, which
is very robust.
And it doesn't
currently-- it's not
supported on devices
that were customized
for alternative stores.
And is this something
that Google feels
is a problem or an unnecessary
burden to developers?
And is there any direction of
moving forward about unifying,
being able to create a
solution that prevents people
like myself from having
to have multiple versions,
different binaries
that I'm submitting
to different locations?
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
it's a good question.
I think-- one of the
points that you mentioned
is that you have the
flexibility on Android to create
a variety of binaries
and to tailor them
based on the device or the
market or the particular store.
There's a number of
definite stores out there
that also offer
analytics services
and other capabilities.
On one hand, you definitely
have a lot of flexibility
there where you can create
all these different binaries
and tailor each one to
the stack of services
that you expect to have
on that user's device.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
I haven't actually heard
your exact question
before around how the
Play Services connects
in those other environments.
I have to think about that.
I mean, I think
usually what people
want to do is either create
a very specific binary that's
integrated with what's happening
in that alternative app store.
So I haven't actually
heard about people saying
that they would
want to try to use
Play Services with
those other app stores
because I think-- again,
depending on what market you're
looking at, those users
may or may not even
have those services
installed on their devices.
So it would depend.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think it's a
particularly painful point
with push notification.
That can be something that's
a challenge for especially
smaller development teams.
ELLIE POWERS: OK.
That's good feedback.
I've actually never heard that
particular feedback before.
So thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELLIE POWERS: All right.
All right.
Well, thank you, everybody.
I really appreciate
all your time today
and all the questions.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]